hey what's up mkbhd here okay so windows
xp
was great
then windows vista
was not great but then windows 7 was
great then windows 8 with the tiles not
great windows 10
great
and now windows 11 no pressure microsoft
but
this is your chance to break that cycle
so today we got a windows 11 reveal the
newest next version of windows coming as
a free upgrade this holiday season to a
pc near you now it's funny a lot of you
probably know me as a mac user most of
the time just because i've used a lot of
macs here at the studio but that's not
actually because of
mac os
i switched to mac os for the most part
at work because of an app because of
final cut pro so i'm perfectly happy to
spend time in windows all the time and
so watching their unveiling event today
actually felt more compelled to react to
this windows unveiling than anything
they've done over in apple camp lately
in the desktop stuff at the end of the
day though it's just an operating system
and you're gonna have to run apps on it
so we'll get to the app situation in a
minute but there's plenty of interesting
stuff now that they're doing here in
windows 11. so first of all the whole
aesthetic is refreshed pretty
dramatically so we got this new design
that i would describe as very
glassy like there's a lot of shininess
and transparency and glassy translucent
elements things happening through here
as much as it's probably cringe to say
it it kind of does remind me a little
bit of the hype around windows vista
when we had that super flat windows xp
and then vista was all this glass but of
course now it's much brighter and
lighter and i'm just gonna stop
mentioning vista now there is a new
start menu in windows 11 which might
make you a little nervous if you're
familiar with them messing with the
start button and the start menu in the
past but it's pretty good it's actually
centered now by default to keep with the
theme that windows 11 should be the
center of your ecosystem but you can
always move it back over to the left if
you want but yeah it has the glassy look
it also now has suggestions for apps and
documents to open that you recently used
makes a lot of sense here and then
similar to how on android you could
swipe over to see a google discover page
or on ios how you could swipe over to
see a bunch of widgets with information
or even on the mac you could do this now
on windows 11 you can swipe over and you
get a pane of widgets with information
customized by ai so it's this glassy
pullover and i assume it'll get better
over time as it learns you but it has
some level of customization and so you
can see things like weather and news
stories and social posts all over here
and you can fully swipe over to go full
screen with this if you want to just
live here for a little bit it's pretty
cool then here's an interesting no doubt
pandemic inspired feature
microsoft teams is now built into
windows natively
now okay here's the thing so microsoft
teams i get it it's their communication
app they want to use it as much as
possible but also
uh microsoft owns skype
and they bought skype for 8.5
billion dollars so when i when i think
of what microsoft could do to like make
communication easier in windows that's
just what came to my head but you know
they're trying to promote teams and make
it the default messaging app and push it
more among regular people so the demos
they were showing in this event were
just people having chat conversations
with friends and family and just hopping
on casual video calls and microsoft
teams now i don't know about you but
i've always thought of teams as a
business app like a corporate video
conferencing app because that's the only
thing i've actually used it for it's
literally called teams so i kind of
wonder if building it into windows will
actually have the intended effect like
it's coming out during the holiday
season which is in a couple more months
so again we'll probably want to be
mostly done with video calls by then but
even for casual video calls
like zoom
definitely broke through from the
enterprise to like being the default
video calling app for the world
microsoft like i said owns skype but
also now facetime
from this recent ios update will allow
you to send links to people on android
phones and and web devices and windows
users can jump on facetimes now so yeah
i don't know if microsoft teams is going
to be that
thing that hard hitting standard default
but we'll see i do love though the new
window management controls this is
something windows has been ahead on for
a while and they're still great at now
in windows 11 you hover over the
maximize button i believe and you get
all these new multi-window snap presets
super dope for people who work with
multiple windows open all the time like
i do and also joanna stern has an
awesome exclusive piece over on the wall
street journal right now that posted
today you should definitely read it i'll
link it below and in that she mentions
there will be a windows like
memorization basically
with external displays
now so if you've ever had an external
display with a windows laptop in the
past it's kind of annoying when you have
a bunch of stuff nicely laid out on that
monitor and then you unplug it and
things all just appear on your laptop
not anymore now they will memorize their
location on that monitor when you unplug
the monitor they'll all minimize and
when you plug that monitor back in
they'll all go back to where they were
that's pretty dope but the biggest new
thing the biggest most headline-worthy
new feature from windows 11 that caught
my eye the most has to do with apps so
so this is the headline ready this is
what can be printed up at the top super
simply
android apps
can now run natively
in windows 11. so right off the bat that
is pretty cool they're showing it's
compatible with the window management
controls and it can potentially give you
access to a whole new suite of millions
of apps that we all know and love
working perfectly on the desktop or the
laptop or the two in one that you carry
whatever runs windows you got to bring
the most popular apps to windows to get
people to use windows right but there
are some more details behind that super
simple headline so this is made possible
through a collaboration actually between
microsoft and amazon so actually what's
going on here is it's loading up the
amazon app store for android apps
into the microsoft windows
app store and this is all going to be
run through intel bridge technology so
again from joanna's piece she notes that
you'll be able to search through the
windows app store like normal and when
you find an android app in there and you
click to download and install it you
will have to be signed in
to an amazon account because it's coming
from the amazon app store and actually
the first time you ever do this it'll
have you download and install the amazon
app store app for windows which
it's going to haul it'll it's just the
first time but it'll work
and then from there you'll be able to
download all these amazon app store apps
it's not a hundred percent overlap with
the google play store from my experience
it's pretty close but it's the amazon
android app store
loaded up into the windows app store
that makes sense so maybe the headline
should really read uh android apps
that are in the amazon app store
will work natively kind of on windows 11
as long as you have a microsoft and
amazon account basically it just feels
like a super official side load it
doesn't quite feel native but they'll
try to make it feel as native as
possible the move to do this by the way
makes perfect sense like meet the people
where you want them to be with their
apps that they already like it's the
same reason you can run android apps on
a chromebook and you can run ios apps on
a mac it doesn't mean they're going to
be good like there's a bunch of bad
examples of them not really working
great they might suck for non-touch
input
they might just have functions that are
broken or just don't work as well when
they're on a computer versus when
they're actually on a mobile device so
it's maybe the most convoluted version
of it all but at the end of the day you
can say you offer
android apps on windows sure so those
are all the big new changes the huge
bullet points windows 11 is looking
fresh and clean with this new aesthetic
and i for one am definitely on board
with that part it feels modern and
there's lots of other behind the scenes
and under the hood changes as well i'm
sure it's 64-bit only for one and
there's also a couple other more
interesting new system requirements so
there's a compatibility tool that people
can use now to check if their pc they
currently have will work with windows 11
but i think we'll learn a lot more as
the betas start rolling out people start
using them about graphics improvements
and security and privacy and
optimizations and all that fun stuff but
in the meantime
that's windows 11.
so not bad i'm impressed
i think they might have just
broken the cycle
the on off i don't want to jinx it but i
kind of like this update we'll see let
me know what you think in the comments
section below if you have any strong
thoughts on the new design or any of the
stuff we've talked about here let me
know if you also actually care about
running android apps
on windows i'd be super curious thanks
for watching catch you guys in the next
one
peace